In an arguably seminal 2011 blog post,
titled The Rise and
Fall of HL7, Eliot Muir,
founder and CEO of Interfaceware,
a major Toronto-based HL7 solution
provider wrote complicated
standards can be pushed for a while,
but ultimately markets reject them.
Muir went on to recommend
a web services approach.
Australian standards guru Grahame Grieve
added a simplified data model,
based in part on HL7 RIM, and
named it Fast Healthcare
Interoperability Resources, or FHIR.
It's now a part of HL7 and
seems to be spreading like its homonym,
fire, F-I-R-E.
I introduced FHIR way back in lesson one
as a universal health app platform and
you're using it that way for
your team projects.